- Hey, everyone.
Welcome to another Coffee Break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
As you know, on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So over the last year or so,
one thing changed for sure.
And this is that people
spend much more time
in front of their desk at home
than they used to in 2019 and before.
So what does this mean?
People are wondering, how
do I equip my desk at home
in the best possible way?
This was surely a question
that I asked myself a
lot in the last months.
So today I wanna show you
how my desk setup looks like
as a C-level executive
at a German startup,
and also as a content producer,
of course, for YouTube.
And as someone who thought a lot
about how to conduct great
and optimal video conferences.
So let me show you around here
in my little content room,
a little paradise here at home,
and let's do it.
So the big challenge that I'm facing
is that we are here in Munich,
which means apartment
prices are quite high.
Also, we don't have a huge apartment here.
So it's limited space.
We have this little room here
that I use for content creation
and for work in general.
Which of course puts me
in a bit of a tough spot,
that I need to make this multifunctional.
So here we just have a simple cabinet,
to store away some stuff.
What you see here is
my silver play button,
my Silver YouTube Play Button.
So for the uninitiated,
once you pass 100,000
subscribers on YouTube,
YouTube sends you this
nice little thing here.
So pretty cool, indeed.
Quite proud of it, I must say.
I think the next one that you get
is only for one million subscribers.
Then you get a bigger one in gold.
So still a long way to go.
Thanks again for everyone who subscribes,
who supports the channel.
But now let's maybe
get really to the core,
to the center of this room.
And this is of course here, my desk.
And I will show you all the
individual pieces in a moment,
go more into detail of all of this.
Probably the thing that you
will undoubtedly notice here
are this soundproofing
material at the wall.
So as you can imagine,
this took quite a lot of
discussions with my wife,
for her to allow me to put
all of this here on the wall,
given that, again,
we don't have that many
rooms here in the apartment.
So it's quite a significant
part of the flat.
The reason that I did there
is just that the wall
has quite a lot of echo,
quite a lot of reverb here in the room,
Which is of course not
great for two reasons:
first, obviously for creating videos,
but also in video conferences.
So I don't know how you feel about it,
but I always notice it,
whenever I'm in a video
conference with someone else
and lots of reverb, lots
of echo in the room,
really not a great experience,
especially if you sit
together in a longer meeting.
So this really helps.
Frankly, there's still quite
a problem with a reverb
in this room.
So this improved it, but not solved it.
So that's the soundproofing thing.
Then you, here, of course
see the two lights.
Again, two things, two purposes.
I do many videos where I just
sit here in front of my desk,
and just create a video with a camera
directly pointed towards me.
Of course,
lighting is really one of
the most important things
when creating videos.
By the way, most of the
products that I will show you,
I will include links to them
in the video description.
So feel free to just check them out,
if you feel like this is something
that might be relevant to you as well.
So we'll show you more in detail
on what exactly I have here
on my desk in a moment.
Let me just quickly finish
by showing you the rest of the room,
because indeed what you
have here to my left
is this little cabinet with the TV.
And then of course,
lots of room here to stow away things.
So here you just have
all my audio equipment
and actually also my gimbal.
Here you have my old camera
that served me very well
on my first year on YouTube.
Here's some additional
lenses for my camera,
and use some other more
or less gimmicky equipment
that I use for this.
So definitely some great
room and things that I use.
Here, this is one of the big things
that I'm just not really sure
about how to make use of this here.
Of course, this light is just here
for the purpose of this video,
to better light up the room.
That's not usually here.
What you see here is this
big empty white wall.
What do I do with this wall?
Please let me know in the comments,
give me some suggestions.
This is the wall directly
opposing my desk.
So the war that is often in the background
when I create a YouTube video.
And of course it looks a
little bit boring, right?
So I could probably do
some cool stuff with that.
I was thinking about
putting some additional
sound-proofing material here.
So this would be one option,
but then of course, maybe
not the best aesthetics.
If you have some great
ideas, just let me know.
And then of course,
last but not least here,
this section with this couch,
and also this background here.
One thing that I am thinking about
is potentially to take
away this little thing here
and maybe put a Firm
Learning sign in neon lights.
So some like lighting installation
that says Firm Learning here in the back,
because this would then
potentially allow me
to do some video scenes where I stand here
with this as a background.
This might actually be
quite a nice background then
if there's a nice Firm Learning
thing here on the back.
Let me know what you think.
Potentially, this could also
be a nice podcast setup.
So I'm thinking about maybe
at some point in the future
to start a podcast,
then I could sit here
maybe with some guests,
Firm Learning in the back,
and maybe a little table,
just some ideas.
But let me know what you think
about that in the comments.
But now given that the focus of this video
is my desk setup, let me
show you exactly that.
And probably the key piece here
is shortly the display, the monitor.
So I was looking for
an ultra wide monitor.
I believe this monitor
has 38, yes, 38 inches.
So quite a big thing.
I wanted a very big one.
Frankly, when I ordered it,
I expected that it's so big
that it might even be too much.
If I now think back at it,
probably also wouldn't have hurt
if it would have been
even in a bit larger.
So for me, the size is
surely not too large,
so truly not too wide.
Let's put it this way.
And of course the funniest
thing is the packaging
that this came in.
So let's see if I find it in here.
So this is the packaging of the two lights
that were behind my desk.
(bright music)
So look at this beauty,
this is quite a package.
It's also still pretty heavy,
even though the monitor
was taken out of it.
So this is what you can
expect if you order it,
I will link it in the video description.
I'm very satisfied and
happy with the quality,
very excellent display.
Check it out if this is something
that you feel like you would like to have.
And now back to the desk.
Another thing that I got, and
actually like quite a lot,
is this mouse.
This is the Logitech MX Master Three.
So it's a mouse that I
feel like at the moment,
a lot of people are getting,
and I can understand why.
So I saw it also with some
other YouTubers who got this.
I think one of the greatest things
is really the scroll wheel,
which has also two scroll wheels here.
So just check it out, try it out.
It's really a cool mouse,
which also helps a lot when
you edit video, for instance,
because then you can do
some horizontal scroll
on the Premiere Pro timeline.
So for those people interested
in things like this,
this is quite handy.
Another thing that I have here
is just the nice Logitech keyboard.
So I thought that the wire
wouldn't distort me too much.
Frankly, now it does.
So I mean, obviously
you do your own choices,
but if I would now get a new one,
probably I wouldn't get
one with a wire anymore.
But again, I will link all these things
in the video description,
in case you are interested in them.
And then what you see
here is also my laptops.
So I have quite a bunch of
laptops that I circulate.
This is not my work laptop.
So it's a classic, ThinkPad X1.
I will also link the model that I have
in the video description,
in case you're interested to check it out.
Another thing that I use
quite a lot, frankly,
not even so much for my video productions,
because there I use the same
microphones for the cameras,
but what I use quite a lot
for my video conferences,
is this one.
This is a Blue Yeti USB mic.
What's great is that it's
really just powered by USB,
just stick it in the computer,
and it's plug and play.
So no complex audio interfaces
or anything like that.
And this gives quite good sound,
also for a pretty decent price
for what this is costing you.
So if you are doing lots
of video conferences
and wanna make sure that your sound,
your audio is very good,
can very much recommend
you to get a mic like this,
obviously then what you
need are some headphones.
So often I just use Airpod Pros,
Apple Airpod Pros to
get this done as well,
because otherwise it
might have some reverb
also in the audio, some disturbances.
But this one, a really great thing.
And then last but not least,
are some speakers that I have here.
So these are the Audioengine
A2 Plus, or something like this
is what they're called.
Again, I will leave this to you as well,
if you're interested in
that, check them out.
I think also pretty good sound.
And just got annoyed over
time, because in the beginning,
I always had the sound
just via the laptop,
which of course is not
the best experience.
And then it's also just coming
from one corner of the table,
just all the time, this
disturbed me quite a lot.
Of course, also for video editing,
but just for general
desktop browsing experience.
So this investment definitely paid off
just to provide a proper
sound experience here.
Then the next thing that
I use is the camera.
Of course, this is really my main camera
that I also use for YouTube.
It's a Sony a7S III.
So frankly, quite an expensive one.
So I wouldn't us it just for regular use,
if you don't have a proper purpose for it.
Nevertheless, I will also
link this model here.
But what I do also use it
for are video conferences.
So you can connect your camera to the PC
and then use it as a webcam if you like.
Really for your video conferences,
this really gives just a superb image.
It's really standing out.
I can especially recommend this to you.
If you just, you do lots of
video conferences in general,
maybe you even work in sales,
conduct lots of sales calls,
surely a camera like this,
of this quality, is not needed.
But if you are willing to invest 500,
maybe a thousand euros in a great camera,
this will really make a difference.
You will really stand out in
all these video conferences.
To connect this to the PC.
I have a little gadget.
It's an Elgato Cam Link 4K that I use.
In theory, I could even do
a video conferences in 4k
with this.
Obviously, this will be a
little bit of an overkill.
As you can see,
the camera is now standing
on a stand by itself.
But this is a so-called Gorilla Pod,
that you can screw this in.
So you can use this also to
put other kinds of cameras
on top of it, all kinds of
devices, mobile devices.
So pretty handy, just you
can flexibly rearrange it,
depending on what you need.
What you see here on the
back is a little dock.
I got the ThinkPad dock
that I use really to just have one cable
that goes into the laptop
to connect the laptop to the whole setup.
This is of course, very handy.
If you just wanna take the laptop,
put it in your bag, go to your office.
And then even in come back,
if you are working in the office,
plug it back in and it all runs.
You don't need to connect
lots and lots of cables
to the laptop.
This is definitely a change up.
And then what you see
here also is my phone.
Obviously I have a smartphone, an iPhone.
Not the newest one.
It's an old one that I
purchased from my sister.
So I believe this is an iPhone X.
I think it's already like
four or five years old.
So my sister got an upgrade,
and then she sold me her old phone
and now I'm using it, and I'm
feeling quite okay with it.
Here I have an induction charging device.
I just put this on.
I can also use this to
charge the Airpod Pros.
Last but not least,
maybe let's quickly also
talk about the chair.
This is actually quite a nice chair.
It's pretty odd to have
it since high school,
so over 10 years old.
I know that at the time,
it was really a good one.
So it wasn't a super cheap,
but it definitely was worth it
given that I'm still using it today.
Frankly, I don't know
anymore where it's from,
or how I got it.
But very nice comfy chair,
can definitely recommend
to you to get some of this as well,
because in front of the desk,
you just will spend
many, many hours usually.
And it's definitely a difference.
So to sum up, I think nothing too crazy.
What really making a difference
for me is first the display,
having a big display with
lots of screen estate,
screen real estate here.
Second, proper camera,
and proper microphone
for your video conferences.
This is not only helpful
for producing videos,
but for producing content in general.
And last but not least,
some proper lighting.
Again also for video conferences,
this will make a good difference
and will make you look
much more professional
than maybe you would
have just using a laptop,
and then the built-in
camera in the laptop.
Of course you don't need these
professional grade things.
Simpler devices than the
one that I showed you
that I will link below,
will definitely suffice.
But look at this, trust that
it will make a difference
for you this way.
So I hope you found this insightful,
potentially also took
away some inspirations
for your setup at home.
Let me know in the comments,
what you think about the things
that I showed here today.
Of course, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to stay up to date
and all my content.
Big, big, thank you to all the members
supporting the channel.
My name is Heinrich.
I release videos every single Saturday.
See you again next week.
Until then all best, and bye-bye.